I was 12 in year eight so about 13 years
old I was 15. basically all of my
friends did it so I just hung around
with them so much that I was like why
not these are the voices of secondary
school children who all Vape we're not
giving their names to protect their
privacy the main reason why I Vape it's
not the feeling it's not the flavor it's
the tricks that's what you see on social
media as well you mean like making
shapes with the with the smoke yeah yeah
it's almost like I'm doing it to look
cool they're speaking to FYI that's
Skies news and current affairs program
for children about why they do it my
friends they'll be doing it in school
and the toilets and stuff like that and
they can't go a day without doing it and
they're not alone latest figures from
the NHS suggest nine percent of 11 to 15
year olds do it despite it being illegal
I definitely sound addictive like every
two or three days after I buy another
one and everything so I do spend quite a
lot of money on it as well and then like
you're basically paying to have problems
with your body obviously but it's kind
of hard to get off here when like all
your friends are doing it you just don't
want to be the only one out now the
government is launching a Crackdown on
the illegal sale of e-cigarettes to
under 18s and Rishi sunak says he's
particularly concerned about vaping ads
that appear to Target children it's
illegal to salvage to children but yet
we know that the more and more young
people are and we want to stop that
but is this enough
I'm Leah bellesso and this is the Sky
News Daily
in a minute I'm going to be speaking to
a head teacher and also someone from The
Vaping industry but first I thought it
would be a good idea to hear a bit more
from some of those teenagers
you get told so many things from
different people like my one of my good
friends who's 18. she stopped vaping
and then she got an after effect from
the stopping it she got gum disease from
stopping vaping and then other people
were telling me like the man that serves
me in a shop he tells me that there's no
problem with vaping so you get really
mixed signals and I guess I'm just not
paying much attention to the bad side as
much as I should
I did see that it does affect health and
I don't do it as much as I did but I was
never really bothered by it because I'm
young and I was like I only live once so
like do whatever
what I find a bit weird is that on
cigarette packets they have the photos
the warnings telling you to stop
but in Vape ones they don't and if it's
such a big deal when all these problems
are happening why are they not putting a
photo warning on on Vapes
I'm incredibly worried I mean it is
easier for you to buy a vape pen than it
is paracetamol if you're a young person
that seems to me to be the wrong way
around this is glimpots he's the head
teacher at John Henry Newman Roman
Catholic College in Oldham he looks
after 1 500 pupils and he's really
concerned about how many of his students
vape we just simply haven't regulated it
enough quick enough to make sure that
the young people who are attracted by
these ineligently bright colorful uh
packaging where flavors are I believe
targeted at young people like bubble gum
flavor
we haven't kept pace and that risk then
is translated to our young people and I
for one am campaigning to try and make
sure that this is brought to curb
because I don't believe it's in the best
interest of our young people but Glenn
isn't it just normal for kids to
experiment you know Break The Rules
every now and again
I think all schools will face some
indiscretions with young people and
traditionally we may well have thought
of those as things such as the old
smoking behind the bike sheds but as
technology around vaping and
E-cigarettes has changed this has become
far more difficult for us to both
monitor but equally to advise the young
people on it and we are seeing more
young people using vape pens than I
would I would really like to and it's
causing some issues for us what type of
issues what's going on well I think from
the the first major issue for me is the
welfare of our young people you know I
want to be a positive advocate for for
them a voice for for the difficulties
they face particularly during covid and
so on and so forth and they want answers
around what they believe to be a safer
option than smoking which is vaping but
they're not grasping the fact that these
vape pens often are poorly constructed
they often have higher levels of
nicotine in them than actual cigarettes
which is therefore a Gateway access into
smoking and we don't know the long-term
health challenges that such activity do
to our young people and there is some
evidence about the impact and negativity
towards adults but very little towards
uh young people and I think that that
means that that they are often taking a
very very risky gamble with their health
how big a problem do you think this is
becoming for young people it's created a
bit of an undercurrent of challenge
where we know young people are using
them to uh to gain money but equally to
pass on debts between each other for
pens that they may have used for flavors
that they've pre-ordered off a friend or
from the fact that um for some of them
they contain THC or CBD oils linked to
marijuana which they believe are going
to give them the same high or the same
health benefits that they're seeing on
on the internet and therefore all of
that just creates a an atmosphere of
risk and as teachers it's incredibly
difficult for us to combat that but it's
equally difficult for us to be able to
advise young people on on how to avoid
those matters other than simply say
don't take the risk gosh that's such a
nightmare isn't it for parents for
teachers to try and control what are you
telling your young people about the
dangers how are you trying to get a grip
on it
you know there is some parents who
believe that that vaping is the lesser
of the evils to smoking and and it just
fundamentally isn't with the amount of
nicotine in vape pens and there are
those parents who use phrases like well
we're a smoking household so if they're
on that at least I know that it's not
going to harm them so we do work with
individual parents we do work with with
our year groups around uh curriculum and
education but but we're also working
with our partners in the NHS our
partners in the police to try and make
sure that the Avenues whereby these
things can be used for negativity are
curtailed and narrowed but it seems that
every time we take a step forward the
organizations Beyond us take two or
three larger steps ahead away from us
because of the the sheer volume of use
of these and the money that's involved
the World Health Organization says that
the consumption of nicotine in Children
and adolescents has damaging impacts on
brain development and potentially leads
to learning and anxiety disorders but if
you type NHS teenagers vaping advice
into Google then you don't get any of
that there are a couple of news articles
with those stats I gave you at the start
of this episode that there's been an
increase in vaping amongst teens but the
top results is an NHS page called vaping
to quit smoking and it tells me nicotine
vaping is substantially less harmful
than smoking it does also say vaping is
not recommended for non-smokers and
young people because it's not completely
harmless but it seems like there's just
not much easily accessible information
out there for kids who want to learn
more and there hasn't been extensive
research into the impact of vaping on
children
now this is something that vaping
manufacturers recognize John Dunn is
director general of the UK vaping
industry Association
I'm a father of two children myself so
you know I don't want to see any young
person vaping at all and it really comes
down to how they're getting a hold of
these products
um and we've been pushing the government
actually to take more action and
stronger action for a number of years
now and one of the things that we're
concerned about is the fines that
retailers receive if they're unlucky
enough to be caught is only around about
200 to 250 pounds
um up to a maximum of two and a half
thousand pounds which frankly I I don't
know a single retailer that's ever
gotten find that now we want that fine
to be increased to ten thousand pounds
per instance to make it really hurt for
these Road traders who frankly don't
care who they sell the products to we
also want to see the licensing of Vape
retailers because I go out with trading
standards I go out in the street and see
it myself we've got pizza shops selling
these things hairdressers you know it's
an age-gated product it's illegal for
anybody under the age of 18 to buy these
products but many of these retailers are
either oblivious to that or or they
don't care about that and we think
that's a huge problem
and what do you think the industry needs
to do then you're saying fines need to
be bigger that makes sense but then when
you look at the packaging that's where I
have a big problem as a parent you know
some of them look like sweets they're
very colorful you've got some that are
even reminiscent to toys like with
unicorns on if you're a smoker and you
want to quit smoking you're not going to
need Vapes that are similar to Sweet
packaging it's just not necessary that
needs to change surely I absolutely
agree with you on that now colors are
often used with many products including
adult products to denote different
flavors so I don't have a problem with
that but what I do have a problem with
is like cartoon characters for instance
or brands that blatantly rip off
um you know well-known sweet Brands like
Skittles Etc now technically they're
they are illegal you it's not you're not
allowed to do that but one of the issues
that we have is there is a registration
process that brands that contain
nicotine have to go through here with
the mhra
but the mhra doesn't look at things like
product design they don't look at
packaging design so they're really only
going by the name of the product and in
many cases things like that slip through
now we think that's a mistake I think
all of those factors need to be looked
at by the MH array who are the
regulatory body before they give the
approval for these products as John says
mhra which is the medical and Healthcare
products regulatory agency do have rules
about how products that sell nicotine
are labeled but they don't control
everything about what they look like or
how they're advertised now this is
something that's recently been picked up
by the Prime Minister who says that
vaping ads that appear to Target
children are not right the adverts for
these things are designed to appeal to
kids you know with the colors they use
the characters they use flavors this is
all things that shouldn't be happening
well first of all you know as we said it
is illegal for anybody to under the age
of 18 to vape it is not designed for
anybody who doesn't currently smoke and
if you're a smoker it is you know a far
better thing for you to do smoking you
know will kill you one in two people who
smoke will die from smoking related
diseases both if my parents died that
way and that's one of the reasons why
I'm so passionate about this but you
know what we've got to look at is we've
got to look at the evidence as compared
to smoking I think it's really healthy
isn't it to have a conversation around
the fact that that children in
particular should not have nicotine in
their system we have research backed by
the National Health Service in this
country that says you know there's been
a rise in young people picking up these
devices consuming them and the
implications that has had on their
health that we're all worried about
we're all concerned about and we simply
don't have enough information now
at this moment to say what the long-term
implications might be on young people
that's a worry you're not getting any
argument from me that's that's that's
why you know as a concerned parent
myself what I want to do is I want to
cut off that Supply that's where the
biggest issue is and unfortunately you
know young people are very creative now
in you know in how they get information
on where they can get these products you
know in the old days like like we were
talking about you know you always knew
that news agency would tell your friend
where they would go now they put it on
Instagram and Twitter and Snapchat and
all of these other apps you know so that
information gets gets pushed around
so John it's curious to me as a as a
parent as you know head of this man
manufacturer
um how do you feel about where this
industry is going because we're aware
that kids will find a way of getting
Vapes and and there's a worry over the
health implications for them what
conversations do you have with your kids
about vaping I I have I have very open
and honest you know discussions with my
kids and I'm lucky they don't smoke they
don't vape and they barely drink you
know but that's not because they didn't
have access to the products you know I
always have samples in my house so they
could easily access if they wanted to
but I just talked a bit about the facts
you know vaping is not cool it's not a a
smart thing to do you know luckily they
just they aren't influenced by you know
their peers but it is tough for kids
these days there are so many influences
out there they try to emulate people on
social media and things and that's one
of the reasons why you know for me I
don't think vaping has any place on
social media you know especially on on
platforms like Tick Tock for instance
but there seems to be reluctance with
these type of platforms to do any age
gauging or any restrictions
John says that retailers need to be held
accountable and social media needs to be
regulated when it comes to vaping but
the companies that make Vapes are
responsible for what they look like and
Recent research by King's College London
suggests that Vapes sold in unbranded
packaging like cigarettes would be less
appealing to teenagers
let's hear from head teacher Glenn again
I think there has to be a completely
regulated area I think also we need to
be working with local trading standards
and with the police in a far more
coordinated effort because some of these
shops will probably make far much more
money off that than selling illegal
alcohol because they know the
consequences of doing illegal alcohol
the young people who are buying these
things are buying them through
challenging circumstances and if we can
come up with a local Solution that's
backed up with statutory law and some
form of fine for shopkeepers and those
who who peddle these kind of things then
hopefully we can avoid the majority of
these young people accessing them
because I believe if they start with
Vapes I think they'll end up with
cigarettes or they'll end up with
something else because the nicotine in
them is sort of such an extreme level
compared to a cigarette that it will
always create that need for them
do you feel you have enough backup to do
all of the things that are needed to
curb children from using Vapes
um I think it's a very difficult
question to answer at the moment but I
think I've got the hardest working staff
in education I know that they will work
with me to support this but we cannot
solve it alone and I think to to push it
on to teachers is not a welcome Factor
but it's one that we take as a moral
duty and an obligation but there really
does need to be some some grown-up
thinking about how we manage this and
moving forward because for everything
we're pushing down to teachers it takes
them out of the classroom and that that
therefore causes more challenges for us
and your message then finally to the
manufacturers who are putting these
Vapes on the shelves and they are ending
up in shops in hairdressers in chicken
shops uh what's your message to them I'd
ask them to step back and think
cautiously about the impact of their
work and the fact that we know a lot
more about cigarettes now do they want
to be remembered in history as ignoring
those messages and therefore harming
young people or do they want to take the
moral High Ground now and prove that
this is an adult option that protects
young people from getting access to it
because I think that they really should
be late taking a really serious look at
their work
I do worry about it a little bit because
like it could be really really bad and
in a couple years I could be in a
hospital somewhere because of it I'm
sure I'm going to look back on it when
I'm older probably when I'm out of my
teens I'll be like why was I even doing
that but I feel like that's a big part
of growing up you do things you're not
supposed to do this is clearly one of
them
my thanks to John Glenn and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Leah belletto this episode was produced
by Emma Ray Woodhouse with Alex Eden and
Rosie Gillett our editor is Philly
Beaumont
foreign